[Music]
when you're flying 40,000 feet high in
the air you want to make sure that
everything goes perfectly fine
you might feel safe up there but that is
because there are so many things you do
not know from things that could save
your life two ways to save money there
are things that most passengers will
never know wait until you hear about how
many pilots all is sleep when they work
if this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are revealing 10 things
airlines don't want you to know the tiny
hole on the window if you ever went on a
plane you probably spent hours looking
around you and wondering what to do on
your uncomfortable seat and if you had
the chance to be sitting close to the
window you probably spent too much time
thinking about why there was a tiny hole
there is it even supposed to be there or
is the plane about to crash to keep the
pressure contained 36,000 feet above sea
level
there can't be holes anywhere so is this
scary little thing trying to end your
life don't worry everything is going to
be fine the tiny holes in airplane
windows called bleed holes are actually
there for your safety there are three
window panes and the hole is located on
the middle one you are not in contact
with the air outside of the plane but
why is it there anyway it reduces the
pressure on the middle pane so only the
outer pane takes the force of the cabin
pressure if one of the panes is broken
we'll still have two others to protect
us next time you're on a plane you'll
have something interesting to say to the
passenger sitting next to you the secret
life of air hostesses these women are
always smiling but that doesn't mean
they're doing the easiest job there are
so many things you don't know about
being an air hostess first there is a
reason why they look so good some of
them are not allowed to gain weight or
they'll be asked to lose it in a month
there are also strict grooming standards
for their skirt their heels their nails
and even their lips
sticks but that doesn't mean these girls
are superficial they are really smart -
some of them are asked to emergency
procedure questions and one medical
question before the flight air hostesses
are also trained to deliver babies in
midair until the emergency services
arrive they are the one you need if the
plane crashes and you end up on a
television show like lost after years
living on planes and traveling around
the world air hostesses are real-life
survivors these women seem to be perfect
but don't think they are there to flirt
or even make small talk they have a lot
of things to do if they want to make
everyone happy
so go back to work Britney Spears your
influence is toxic for the whole team
but that's not a reason not to give them
tips or gifts air hostesses love to see
that you appreciate all of the things
that they are doing for you the truth
about mobile electronic devices do you
remember when the air hostess asked you
to turn off your cell phone when you
were preparing for takeoff
she never explained why but most of us
thought that the one who left their
phone open would be the reason why the
aircraft crashes and you might be scared
to go on a plane ever again if you know
that four out of ten US air passengers
admitted that they don't always turn off
their electronic devices but why do we
need to anyway that is because it can
cause interferences the gadgets connect
to the internet using radio frequencies
just like the ones the pilots need this
could affect the radar communications
and the collision avoidance technology
some pilots admitted that they missed a
clearance or two because of cell phone
users so it is true that you shouldn't
use mobile electronic devices after all
it is to be taken seriously but that
doesn't keep the crew from breaking this
rule in using their cell phone anyway
just after telling people not to do that
and what happens when a passenger does
the same thing they could be asked to
leave the plane if they refuse to
cooperate just like it happened to actor
Alec Baldwin he refused to stop playing
words with friends and had to be kicked
off before the takeoff
you better not waste your time and
everyone else's life and just turn off
your cell phone let's go ten years back
in time and learn how to live without
our electronic devices the food you eat
anyone who has ever been on a plane
agrees that the food usually looks
disgusting and you're right to think so
most of the staff would never eat the
food that they serve the
pilots don't even have the right to eat
the same meal whether they're on the
plane or their day off that's because
they want to make sure that the two of
them won't get food poisoning and by the
look of it they just shouldn't eat
anything that is served on board and
it's not just the food that you
shouldn't touch the trays don't get
cleaned as often as they should you
might think that the water should be
fine but you are absolutely wrong a test
of tap water from various airlines found
out the bacteria level was as much as
100 times higher than the allowed limit
in the US this is why you'll see most
air hostesses drinking water out of a
water bottle after learning all of this
we don't even feel like eating or
drinking anything anymore anyway you
probably won't even have the opportunity
to eat food service on night flights can
be delayed until most people fall asleep
so they won't have to serve food
sometimes it's better to be hungry than
to be sick the dirty secrets on the
plane it's not only the food that is
disgusting but also everything around
you and once you know this you'll want
to wear a spacesuit the next time you go
on a plane before you touch anything
use sanitizing wipes you never know what
happened and most of the plane isn't
cleaned properly some people don't mind
changing their baby's diaper on the tray
where you eat so when you eat the
pretzel that you just dropped and might
be eating poop at the same time and
don't walk barefoot on the carpet every
discussing thing you can imagine has
been spilled on it like vomit baby pee
and different human fluids in fact don't
even touch the blankets and the pillows
sometimes the crew doesn't even remember
the last time they were cleaned
even if headphones come in wrappers they
have probably been used as well and for
those who think that love is in the air
forget about kissing in secret in the
bathroom this is the least romantic
place you could ever find if you ever
wondered why most air hostesses didn't
join the mile-high club that is because
they know about all the most disgusting
things that happened there forget about
intimacy the staff can open the door at
any time you shouldn't be scared of the
plane crashing you should actually be
scared of staying on board the things a
safety demo doesn't actually tell you
after hours not knowing what to do you
probably read the safety demo five times
and now know how to say it
loud by heart but there are actually
many things you will never know no
matter how many times you read the
pamphlet for example dim lights are not
meant for you to sleep well it is
impossible to have a good night of sleep
on a plane anyway they are meant to
prepare you for evacuation if the
aircraft crashes during the night your
eyes will be used to the darkness and
you'll be able to see more clearly if
the lights are off but that's not all
the real reason why we put up tray
tables during takeoff and landing is so
the passenger next to you can escape
easily you should also open the window
shade so the firefighters can see you if
the plane crashes but there are just
some things you cannot plan many people
steal life jackets to bring them home as
souvenirs the crew makes sure there is
one under every seat at the start of
every day but if there was a flight
before you they might not know that it
has been stolen this is why it would be
a good idea for you to check if the
lifejacket is indeed there the way pets
are treated many people don't want to
leave their pets but sometimes it would
be a better idea to find a babysitter
than to bring them on a plane the
airline is doing their best to protect
the animals but some things can't be
avoided they are left alone during the
whole flight with no food nothing to
drink nowhere to pee and no one a cuddle
if you think that a 12-hour flight is
long just try to imagine what it is like
for them but that is not the worst thing
there is a lot of noise around them and
they could be waiting in the heat cold
or rain on the plane cats and dogs also
have trouble breathing and some of them
can overheat due to high temperatures
and even though the crew does their best
to protect the animal mistakes can
happen your dog could be shipped to the
wrong place or left unattended and if
this happens few airports are equipped
to handle animals waiting for you to
find them could be a life-threatening
experience the best thing to do is take
the animal with you in the cabin but it
is not always possible and only small
animals in a pet carrier are accepted so
if you really love your dog leave them
at home with some ones take care of them
the way bad passengers are treated this
time we have to admit that we don't care
much if bad passengers are not well
treated when the passenger is rude with
the check-in staff some of them make
sure that they'll have a seat in an area
circled with children if you're a
frequent flyer they could even note in
your account that you were a problem
customer and don't expect to get a
flight upgrade if you're demanding and
rude even
one place is available they won't give
it to you those who are upgraded are
usually extremely nice well-dressed and
good-looking but if you really want to
become a troublemaker you'll see that
sitting for hours on a tiny seat isn't
that bad compared to what the crew can
do to stop you you could be arrested
during the flight in case of emergency
the captain can call the authorities so
they take care of you when the plane
lands and while you wait on board the
captain can put you in restraints if
they think you could be dangerous don't
forget that you're not the only one on
the plane and you want everyone have a
good time so even if there's a delay or
someone annoying you don't forget the
staff is doing their absolute best to
handle the situation and you should be
doing the same thing to the best ways to
save money if you are a good customer
there are many ways you can save money
the first thing you want to do is pick
your travel dates wisely in the United
States Tuesday Wednesday and Saturday
are the best days to save money on your
ticket when you want to book a group
trip search for only one ticket at a
time if you are a group of five people
you might not be able to find tickets at
the lowest fare but if you buy five
tickets separately you could save a lot
of money and if you want a better seat
the best time to do it is four days
before your flight this is when airlines
start upgrading fliers and some of the
best seats open up if your flight is
overbooked don't accept the first two
hundred dollar voucher the airline will
keep increasing the offer until enough
volunteers are willing to give up their
seats even if no one wants to accept the
money and you're the unlucky one who
won't have a seat on board insist on
cash compensation you could get as much
as $1,300 in cash depending on the
ticket price and the delay and if your
flight is cancelled there is still a way
for you to get your money back even if
you have a non-refundable fare sometimes
just asking for compensation can solve
all of your problems know what you are
entitled to the danger in the air if you
are afraid that the aircraft might crash
you don't have to worry the odds of a
plane crash are about 1 in 11 million
but this is not a reason not to stress a
little bit did you know that each
commercial airplane is struck by
lightning more than once each year
that seems terrifying but what really
happens when you fly through a heavily
charged region of cloud most aircraft
skins are made of aluminum which
conducts electricity this is why the
Lightning current
on the exterior of the plane the worst
thing that could happen is that you may
see a flash and hear a loud noise so
there's nothing to really be afraid of
what is more dangerous is actually what
happens inside the plane it is expensive
to carry too much fuel because it gets
heavy this is why the airline keeps the
level as low as possible to save money
but this is not a good idea if you want
to save lives if a problem happens and
did you know that pilots fall asleep
while they're flying half of them
admitted that it happened at least once
while flying a passenger plane now that
is something you should be afraid of and
that is it for ten things airlines don't
want you to know that any of these
things happen to you on a plane don't be
shy to tell us in the comments we'd love
to read more about you and for more
stories like that don't forget to
subscribe and watch 10 coolest vehicles
in the world thank you so much for
watching and we'll see you next time bye
bye
[Music]